la famille donne à rémy et ses proches
interrogés par les enquêteurs avaient
rapidement évoqué la personnalité
envahissante et inquiétant ce de son
ancien petit ami d'origine chilienne
qu'elle avait connu au japon et avec
lequel elle avait eu une relation qui
s'était achevée par une rupture de très
nombreux moyens sont actuellement
déployés temps pour retrouver le corps
de la jeune fille que pour faire toute
la lumière sur les circonstances de ce
crime
mais des éléments de l'enquète nous font
dire que même si on n'a pas retrouvé le
corps il est extrêmement vraisemblable
1 c'est la seule hypothèse que que l'on
retient c'est malheureusement que cette
jeune femme est morte